oh
all right
let's do it
[Music]
so today I get to do that thing that I
hate to do but I have to do because I've
set the precedent and if I stop doing it
starts looking like I'm cherry picking
and it's just ah okay
so I have talked in the past about some
actors in major geek related franchises
who have had some scandals not because I
like talking about Scandal I don't but
because those scandals either have or
have the potential to directly impact
the properties that I do care about I've
done it before with Gina Carano I've
talked about Amber Heard I've talked
about Ezra Miller multiple times
and now
we gotta talk about Jonathan Majors who
is part of the MCU currently playing the
recurring villain Kang I say recurring
he's appeared twice so far but
they're planning to do a lot with him
okay
I'm gonna do this the way that I
normally do this I will give you as much
information as currently exists that I
could find at time of recording I am
going to try and get this out today
after I record it which means there
should not be too much time for more
stuff to happen between when I shoot
this and when it goes out who knows but
I am not trying to parse exactly what
the legal outcome of any of this will be
nor am I actually trying to pass direct
um judgment on Jonathan Majors because
ultimately I don't know what actually
happened I know what he's accused of and
I know what's out there and I will talk
about that but the main reason that I
ever talk about this stuff is how it
impacts the future plans of the
properties that these people are part of
because honestly that's the only way I
can digest this stuff is to filter it
through the lens of publicity and
planning and you know creative works
because if I just take it in as gossip
I'm gonna lose my mind real quick
anyways Jonathan Majors on Saturday the
25th of March was arrested following a
domestic dispute resulting in a at
present unnamed woman in her 30s to be
taken to a hospital for minor injuries
to her head and neck Majors was arrested
and charged with assault attempted
assault harassment and aggravated
harassment those might sound somewhat
redundant it's just kind of the way the
legal system especially the criminal
system here works is that you end up
with multiple charges for effectively
the same thing just because of the
specific wordings of each charge and
just how the legal system works but
that's what he was charged with on
Saturday on Sunday the 26th his lawyer
won Priya Chaudhary had proclaimed that
he was innocent you would expect her to
because well
he's her client she's supposed to say
that but she also made the claim that
the victim recanted the accusations
which
I've seen reported a few places but
everywhere that's reporting it only
cites Majors his lawyer as the source on
that and I could not find anything to
corroborate it and somewhat despite that
claim Majors was arraigned later that
same day so if that is true then the
full effects of her having recanted that
have not trickled in and stopped the
process yet or it's also possible that
that wasn't actually what happened but
that's what she said nobody else has
corroborated that and it does not show
up in official records that anything has
been recanted as yet now the various
charges which have already named are
being done as misdemeanors and mages
currently has a May 8th court date now
at time of recording that's pretty much
all we've got actual evidence has not
really been put forward uh Majors his
lawyers said something about a video
that exonerated him but nothing like
that has surfaced if it exists so right
now we've just got someone who claims to
have been assaulted he has been charged
he says he didn't do it that's kind of
all we've got or at least it was
initially now of course initially as a
sort of one person's word against
another people make their own calls on
who they believe barring corroborative
evidence and people will have their own
reasons for having a tendency to believe
one or the other in a situation like
this for in a variety of reasons that I
don't want to get into but what I will
say is there has been
um
corroboration of these specific acts not
that but corroborations that this is not
a typical behavior for Majors now again
this is just coming from a few sources
and I will explain who they are and what
they said the first is film director a B
Allen who back in February tweeted
there's a particular actor relatively
new on the scene who Twitter has
violently Fallen head over heels for who
in actuality is a vicious cruel abusive
human being both professionally and in
his personal life and every new viral
thirst tweet about him drives me insane
now after news of Majors broke a Twitter
user tweeted out a screen grab of that
original tweet from Alan along with the
headline about majors and said well I
guess now we know who that tweet was
about and Alan replied to that just
saying ding ding ding ding in a similar
vein there is Broadway actor and
director Tim Nikolai Nikolai put out a
similar tweet stating it's a strange
relief to know other humans were out
there who understand and who went on to
say that many in the Yale drama school
community of which majors was apart
consider him to be a sociopath and
abuser and it's worth noting that is the
way in which these two people know him
and or people around him so far as I
could tell they have not ever worked
professionally with him but he attended
Yale drama school and you know Works
within or has worked and been known
within same circles that these two
people have uh been in so while these
tweets do not directly corroborate the
specific charges or the specific
incidents they do start to paint a
picture that is going to make it harder
to claim that this is a one-off instead
it at least has the potential to look
like a situation of people knew and
weren't coming forward now both of these
people were actually sort of pressed on
the idea why didn't you say something
and they both gave very similar answers
which basically amounted to because we
hadn't directly experienced these but we
knew people who did we did not feel
comfortable potentially outing victims
who did not wish to be known and
additionally what would our statements
of oh we know someone who this happened
to actually carry but here we get to
just add our voices to something that is
already on the record so that's sort of
their perspective on this it is
interesting noting that both of these
people
have since privated their Twitter
accounts update time that statement was
true at the time I said it however one
of them A B Allen has unprivated their
Twitter account and that actually also
gave me access to another detail that I
think needs to be added in they actually
followed up on their initial ding ding
ding ding reaction to the news having
been broken and their earlier tweet
being tied to Majors they expressed
regret at being as flippant with their
response and also went on to clarify
that they had assumed that there'd been
like some sort of shoving match at a bar
or something at the time they tweeted
that and hadn't looked into it in more
detail because when they did they felt
the need to clarify that their
understanding of what majors was capable
of or had done was much more in the
realm of psychological abuse verbal
abuse not necessarily physical so while
that is not exactly exonerating uh or
completely reversing of their statements
earlier regarding Majors it does paint a
slightly different picture in terms of
what they understand him to be and what
they are claiming he is but let's jump
on back to the subject of the accounts
having been privated even if it was only
briefly in the case of Alan now I was
not able to find any statements from
either of them indicating why they did
that so whether it was they were being
hounded with questions they didn't feel
like answering about Majors or whether
it was they were being hounded with
harassment by people who would prefer to
believe Jonathan Majors I don't know but
given that it happened so quickly after
all this broke I have a very hard time
believing that both of them privateing
their Twitter accounts is not related to
them having spoken out about majors and
an additional follow-up on this as I
said a b Allen has reactivated their
Twitter account but this does kind of
show that at least in their case there
may have been an element of abuse from
supporters of Majors or just people who
rail against anything they perceive as
being canceled culture coming after them
and while they don't confirm that this
Behavior contributed to their
temporarily privateing of the Twitter
account I certainly would not be
surprised because this sort of stuff
yeah yeah it happens a lot so that
brings us to Disney and Marvel and what
the heck do they do now because to say
that Majors is a huge part of what
they're planning to do going forward is
an understatement to date majors has
already appeared in the first season of
Loki as well as Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania in addition to that he has
planned to make multiple appearances
next to going to be seen in the second
season of Loki but he is intended to
appear all over the place if you haven't
really been following Marvel or you
dropped off it here's the really short
version Kang is a time traveler and he
his existence is very much tight at this
point to Marvel's introduction of the
Multiverse meaning there is a multitude
of different variants of Kang we have
encountered two there are many more out
there which could see many many many
potential uses and we already know the
eventual team up that phase I believe
five that we're in right now is going to
eventually be building towards or maybe
even be in phase six at this I don't
know I'm losing track of all that off
the top of my head but eventually it's
all going to build to Kang Dynasty he is
the Thanos of what's going on right now
and much more so than Josh Brolin was as
Thanos he is very much there with his
own face he had some instances of being
heavily cgi'd over but it's him he's
visible you can't replace him easily as
theoretically in a pinch could have been
done with Josh Brolin because well
actually he wasn't even the original
Thanos the Thanos we saw in the Avengers
post-credits sequence was just somebody
they put the effects over in a
silhouette they hadn't even cast the
part yet so Disney has has huge plans
for this guy
so what do they do
now the best outcome for Disney will be
if majors's lawyer turns out to have
been accurate that the victim recanted
and that the charges are then dropped
that is 100 the best case scenario for
Disney because then they can just go
okay there was clearly you know
something happened but there was a
misunderstanding looks like everything's
resolved we can move on but if that
doesn't happen if the uh alleged victim
holds on to her story and if this
actually enters a courtroom then they're
gonna have to make some tough decisions
and the obvious immediate thing to
compare this to would be Ezra Miller
although it's important to know not Ezra
Miller at this stage in Ezra Miller's
whole
thing
because at this point Ezra Miller has
got a protracted history of
nonsense I'm not even gonna begin to get
into it I've had to do multiple videos
on it at this point but
the sort of first initial red flag with
Miller had to do with an incident in a
bar and while Miller was not charged at
that time
this Bears a little bit of a resemblance
of oh boy oh crap did we just put a lot
of a lot of time and effort and Trust
into an actor that is gonna get us in
trouble and Disney on that front is kind
of in a tougher position than Warner
Brother Discovery is because Warner
Brothers doesn't have a family-friendly
reputation to live up to
but Disney does
and that reputation has actually caused
them to make mistakes before it's why
they had the entire debacle firing James
Gunn over dredged up nonsense simply
because it went against their family
value image
so obviously again that all panned out
eventually after a lot of mess
but Disney's very protective of its
brand image and while Marvel is kind of
its own self-contained thing everybody
knows Marvel's own by Disney that's
they're very closely associated at this
point
so what do they do well it's worth
noting that they aren't the only ones
impacted by this the US Army was
actually running recruitment ads
featuring majors and those have been
pulled with the Army stating that while
Mr Majors is innocent until proven
guilty Prudence dictates that we pull
our ads until the investigation into
these allegations is complete which for
the Army is a pretty simple thing they
can run all their ads
but what is Disney looking at
well I think the most immediate question
is going to be on the second season of
Loki now they have a little bit of
wiggle room on this insofar as they
haven't actually confirmed the date
on Loki right now it's mid
2023. now mid could be anything from May
to August so that's a decent enough
window for them to basically kind of
hold out hope and hope the thing
resolves but eventually they're gonna
have to start kicking up the marketing
on that thing
and that's another way in which it kind
of parallels more the more recent stuff
going on with Ezra Miller where Warner
Brothers would never officially
um confirm what they were or weren't
going to do but had to kind of sit tight
and hope that things quieted down and
charges were dropped which for the most
part they have been
so
um they you know they held out and they
were okay Disney's ability to do that
they don't have as much of a Time window
it's also worth noting that things get
complicated in regards to allegations
against uh actors and the specifics of
them because something I didn't get into
last time I talked about Ezra Miller was
that Ezra Miller at the time that I made
the last video I did on them had gone
into some sort of
um treatment for uh mental health and
there are stipulations within uh most
Screen Actors Guild Union contracts that
you can't
fire an actor who is in the process of
undergoing that kind of treatment now
whether or not you can fire them for
having been charged with a crime that's
not exactly the same thing so there's a
little bit more freedom to do it there
but there's always just the general
perception of oh you're gonna fire him
based off an accusation when not only
has it not hit a courtroom yet but there
isn't even like much information out
there and Disney acting too quick again
is what bit them in the ass with James
Gunn so I could see them being reluctant
to do that
but at the same time they're gonna have
to make a choice kinda quick
if I were to guess
I would say that if this does not
basically go away on its own charges
dropped claims recanted and everybody
moves on then I would not be shocked at
all if low-key season 2 gets pushed back
they might claim for something else but
they pull forward whatever stuff they
have in the pipeline that doesn't
feature him
the thing is we don't know how much of
it that is given the way the character
has been designed he could theoretically
be cropping up in almost everything to
some degree now maybe it's a very minor
thing you know just a hint at where
things are building or maybe it's
slightly more substantive uh and harder
to cut out because I mean like in theory
again I'm not trying to pick on Josh
Brolin but if he had caused a problem
back when he was being Thanos if uh if
there was an issue before the release of
the first Guardians of the Galaxy he's
in it and he matters but his actual
appearance could have been cut out and
covered for because it's really only one
or two scenes in that but you know by
the time we were getting into things
like Avengers Infinity War again we're
not that far along in the current phase
but still
it's hard to know which products can be
pulled forward that don't currently
depend on him but definitely the next
one that was coming up Loki season two
yeah we know he was majorly in it
because there was a teaser for it at the
end of Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania
and he was his face was literally the
first thing in the heck teaser
so
there is a lot that Disney's gonna have
to figure out and the thing that I
always say whenever these kinds of
charges come up is whether or not he
retains this position whether or not the
charges are dropped whether or not any
of it
people are going to make their own call
as to whether or not they are
comfortable watching him in this part or
at all and you have every right to do
that
uh you know I'll I'll go back to stuff I
said way back with Gina Carano and
Rosario Dawson and why I was initially
not planning to watch the second second
season of The Mandalorian which was I
just wasn't comfortable watching them
and even if everything panned out fine
you know everything it's all good no
worries like
I just I just didn't want to look at
them it wasn't sitting right with me and
that didn't mean I was calling for them
to be fired that was actually the
initial point of that video that I did
way back when that stuff initially
started breaking this was before Gina
Carana was fired I my thought was no
they don't need to be fired I'm not
gonna watch but they don't need to be
fired so like you have every right to
personally go yeah maybe I'll skip some
stuff because I'm not comfortable seeing
him right now that's you're right
I don't know what Disney should be doing
right now
because like I said in a in an older
situation like a few years ago before
all the Marvel stuff was coming each on
the heels of another one after another
go go go go go go we go back even five
years when there was like two maybe
three Productions in a year
I think they could have shifted stuff
around moved some stuff back but now
like it's it's like four or five
Productions Marvel related Productions
in a year and they're coming out so
rapidly and hat and the Productions are
happening back to back to back to back
that one the wheels come off one aspect
of it there's a domino effect because
these things are all interconnected and
interlocked especially for characters
that are meant to recur over and over
and over again it's sort of it sort of
shows the unplanned for weakness of this
structure I mean obviously there's a lot
of
difficulty trying to do a massive
Cinematic Universe as exemplified by the
fact that so far Marvels are is really
the only one who has pulled it off with
really a high degree of success with
Star Wars coming in maybe second but the
thing is when things are so
interconnected so interdependent so
built one on the other one after another
things like we can't use this actor
anymore
throws a much bigger wrench into things
I mean I can't even begin to imagine how
many plans got scrapped off the death of
Chadwick Boseman
he was somebody they really thought they
were going to have for a long time and
they lost them
now obviously
Majors is not dead but he might be
unavailable depending on how things go
or at the very least he might be uh
uh publicity wise untenable
because the other thing is even if they
keep him it's going to make promotion
difficult
it's gonna make promoting anything with
him in it difficult to cut around
because they're going to want to
minimize his involvement they're
probably not going to be comfortable
sending him out on the uh on the Press
junket to actually promote the thing
because he'll end up getting a ton of
uncomfortable questions
um about what's been going on instead of
about the movie
so
it's gonna hamper things no matter what
in E and that's even if again charges
dropped claims were canted it's still
gonna make things weird and awkward if
they have to start gearing up the
marketing machine in a matter of months
from now
which is why I would not be at all
surprised if Loki ends up getting
delayed at the very least it's gonna
come out as late as it possibly can and
still fit within that mid 2023 claim
which I would say August would be the
latest they could get away with and
claim they released it within the time
frame they said but depending on how
things go depending on whether or not
there's New Revelations depending on
whether or not there's more
corroborations depending on whether or
not this actually sees the inside of a
courtroom
that might not be enough time
so if I were to guess if anything's
going to get delayed it is definitely
going to be low-key season two they
might Shuffle some other stuff around to
give padding to wait until they get to
the next thing that he's supposed to be
involved in whether it's something that
he shot his part four already or not and
just
kind of push it to the back to give this
as much time to in their minds hopefully
play out in a way that is favorable to
him that they can be comfortable using
him again again so it doesn't completely
wreck the brand
but we'll see
this going to court would be worst case
scenario for Disney if this actually
goes to the inside of courtroom because
even though the charges are misdemeanors
if this goes to court
then details are going to come out
explicit details about exactly what he's
accused of and those details even in a
case where somebody is eventually
acquitted the kinds of things that come
out in Discovery in witness testimony if
they bring character Witnesses
definitely
the kind of stuff that can come forward
can be really damaging no matter the
outcome
especially for a brand as concerned with
its images Disney again this would be
way less of a problem if this was Warner
Brothers Sony
Universal anybody other than Disney
's got a much bigger problem when it
comes to something that is going to
taint the image that they have built
their entire brand on
so we'll see what happens but
I guarantee you this is a week
where are a whole bunch of executives
are sweating bullets
and a whole bunch of uh creatives are
sitting on the edge of their seat
waiting to find out how much their plans
are going to get changed
what are your thoughts about all this
uh please avoid
uh derogatory language for any of the
people involved don't do that I'll
delete your comment depending on how
nasty it is I'll block you from
commenting again so like let's
be as polite as possible
that understood drop your thoughts down
in the comments let's talk about it
patreon pays the bills it enables me to
do this as my living any amount you can
contribute there is of immense help even
if you can't like share subscribe help
me out as well don't worry too much
about that though because what I really
want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
foreign
this video wouldn't have been possible
without my supporters over on patreon
and I would especially like to thank
Robin Moore Zubin look fulla Tarak the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters imudelki
Leo the Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky
Sparks bernabi lacks the poodle Robin
Powell Tracy scrabot angry Casper Tim
price Adam RDL Taylor David Hall General
contact unit Problem Child Shayla
gourlay and Rosalind Bennett
thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]